Hoy, pizarritas, tenemos uno de esos drafts que sacan lo peor de nosotros mismos.
Y además en el de hoy no se va a poder repetir ni club, ni país, ni año de nacimiento.
Con estos tres condicionantes tenemos que montar el mejor equipo del mundo.
Adrián Blanco, Álex de Llanó, Nahuel Miranda, ¿estáis preparados?
Papel y bolí, mi gente. Papel y bolí.
We are so ready.
Muy turra este draft.
Es muy difícil este draft.
Aparte, me jode porque he tenido yo la idea de, oye, podríamos hacer un draft.
Pero la verdad que no lo quería tirar por aquí.
Now, now, now, now, now.
Lo vas a disfrutar, Nahuel.
Mi idea, claro, es que yo te dije, Miguel, oye, que tras el marco ha actualizado los valores del mercado de la liga.
Claro, pues ese es otro formatín, el de hacer un equipo Champions con 100 millones.
Eso lo repetiremos, pero estamos en parón de selecciones y hemos dicho, venga, vamos a montar el mejor equipo.
Bueno, hemos dicho no, has dicho tú, Miguel.
Lo he dicho yo.
Yo esto no apoyo, ¿vale?
Quiero que quede claro.
Lo he dicho yo, pero si luego te encanta y, ¡uy, mira qué equipo he hecho!
¡Uy, qué fichaje! ¡Uy, es mi mejor conjunto!
A ver, a ver, a ver.
Me lo tomo de conga, me lo tomo de conga.
Me lo tomo de conga.
Me lo tomo de conga y luego me voy a olvidar.
Es que es el típico, Nauel, es el típico que dice no voy a salir y a las 3 de la mañana llega una cogorza encima.
Ah, Naúl, porfa, coherencia.
Me ha pasado nunca eso.
¡Mis cojones!
Vaya, pues sí.
Que os pase la manita por la cara constantemente en el grab.
Relato, relato, relato.
Bueno, a ver.
Balotelli, Balotelli.
Importante.
El cartero celebra cuando entrega una carta.
Objetivo, montar el mejor equipo del mundo en 2025.
Valoramos al futbolista por su nivel en 2025.
Oye, que alguno puede estar lesionado, no pasa nada.
No nos referimos a estado de forma puntual.
Pero claro, podemos meter a Cristiano o a Messi, pero son los Cristiano y Messi de 2025.
Lo digo para luego evaluar y comparar.
Insisto, no se puede repetir club, nacionalidad, nos quedamos con el país en el que juegue.
Vale.
Sin repetir año de nacimiento, sí edad, pero no año de nacimiento.
Obviamente, no vamos a estar contando meses.
La mía ecuatorial.
Pero ya no puedes escoger Alberto Echeguo entonces.
Claro, Alberto Echeguo de 2025, además que está más fuerte que el de...
O en Sue, o en Sue.
O sea que dale una vueltita.
Lo tacho.
Dale una vueltita.
Now.
Paul Farmer, San Cristóbal y Nieves.
Y luego, para buscar un poquito también de diferenciación, antes permitíamos solo el 4231 barra 442
con las múltiples trampas que siempre intentan los sospechosos habituales.
Ales Deano.
Abrimos el abanico con 4231, 433, 442 y 352.
Pero ojo, escrupulosos en las posiciones.
No quiero de extremo por una banda, a la Minyamal y por la otra a Cuarobasgelia.
Vale.
No.
Bueno.
¿Por qué no?
No.
Sí, Cuarobasgelia ha jugado a la izquierda.
Ese no es un buen ejemplo.
Digo de carrileros.
No, en un 433 sí.
Digo no, es que has dicho extremos.
Perdón, perdón.
Las bandas, perdón.
Perdon, perdón.
Ya empezamos con las trampas.
No engañéis a mi padre.
¿Y sabéis qué otra cosa no quiero ver hoy?
A ver.
¿Me toca a mí?
¿Me toca a un...?
Os aprendéis el orden que vamos a sortear ahora.
Yo me lío.
Os lo aprendéis.
Yo me lío porque hay jugadores...
¿Sabes lo que dicen a los niños de...
No tienes que pensar en quién va primero.
Céntrate detrás de quién vas.
Ya está.
Le coges del bavi, ¿vale?
Si te toca detrás de Adri, le coges del bavi a Adri
y vas detrás de él como si fuese Marcaja el hombre.
Marcaja en individuo.
Como si fuese Battismendy y Adri fuese Pedri.
¿Vale?
Vale, vale.
Sorteamos el orden.
Ya sabéis, juego popularmente conocido, al menos en Madrid, como chinos.
Sacar la manita del 1 al 5.
Empiezo contando a partir de mí y a ver a quién le toca primero.
Una, dos, tres.
Ocho, nueve.
Yo no tengo, ¿eh?
Uno yo, dos Adri, tres Ales, cuatro...
Son diez, son diez.
Te has puesto cuatro a Adri y cinco, yo uno.
Ah, vale, perdón.
Vale.
Yo primero, segundo Adri.
Día 37 pidiendo...
Tres, cuatro, cinco, seis, siete, ocho, nueve, diez.
Lo mejor es que me tocaba a mí primero con nueve
pero le toca con diez Adrián Blanco.
Entonces, Adri es el primero.
Ales el segundo, Navuel es el tercero.
Yo soy el último, por enésima ocasión.
Tendré dos selecciones seguidas, igual que Adri.
Nunca tendrán dos seguidas ni Ales ni Navuel.
O sea, a mí nunca me tocan dos seguidas.
Eso ya está...
Te ha tocado el segundo.
Te ha tocado el segundo, pedazo de ratón.
Pedazo de ratón te ha tocado el segundo, ¿vale?
Así que menos quejas.
Arrancamos.
Con Adrián Blanco Parera.
¿Con quién te quedas?
Año 2007.
Fútbol Club Barcelona.
Selección española.
La Minya Mal.
Vale.
Fácil.
Navuel Miranda.
O sea, perdón.
Ales de Llano.
Joder, iba a decir coño, yo pensaba...
¿Qué me tocaba a mí?
Pero he jugado con la cabeza de Navuel Miranda.
Hay veces que solo dejas el camino de la violencia.
Nunca hay que tomar el camino de la violencia.
Alex.
Vale.
Selección muy complicada la de Alex de Llano, la verdad.
Sí.
La mía está cogido, Alex.
Ya lo sé, ya lo sé.
Pues voy a tirar como si esto fuera al fantasy.
Kylian Mbappé.
Francés, Real Madrid, año 1998.
Vale.
Nació 22 días y 4 años después de mí.
De delantero, ¿no?
Obviamente.
Es que voy a jugar.
Voy a jugar.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Juega delantero.
Que mi estrategia es jugar, pero porque ya veréis.
Navuel Miranda.
Eh...
Ostras, me estoy encontrando el año.
Dame un segundo.
Pero bueno, voy a ir con el buen amigo, nació en el año 92, extremo derecho del Liverpool, Mohamed Salah.
Muy buena.
Muy bien.
Yo lo tenía entre mis primeras elecciones y no tenía uno de los primeros picks.
Pero me voy a quedar con...
A ver.
Mi primer pick va a ser...
Erling Brauhalan.
Aaaaah.
Año 2000, noruego.
Lo cual me convence bastante.
Y me voy a codar con...
Con...
Pedri, año 2002, como centrocampista.
Español, obviamente.
Por suerte y por la madre de la gracia de Dios.
Te toca.
Vale, he hecho Haaland.
Navuel Miranda.
Sí, sí.
Eh...
Voy a gastar...
Portugal, año 2000, Vitor Machado Ferreira.
Viteña.
¿Año has dicho, perdona?
2000.
Vale.
Álex de Llano.
Perdonad, en el tema del sistema, habíamos dicho que el 4-3-1 valía.
Sí.
Pero el media punta tiene que ser media punta.
Porque no va a valer.
Es que le estoy viendo venir.
Es el hombre, recordemos, de Fran.
Y Valerón, eh.
Y si graben también.
Sabemos que el noveno pick de Álex de Llano, porque nunca es el undécimo ni siquiera,
va a ser increíble.
Pues mira, tengo muchas dudas aquí, pero...
Pero voy a tomar esta decisión.
Mi doble pivote va a estar formado en una de esas posiciones
nada más ni nada menos que...
Moises Caicedo.
Chelsea-Ecuador 2001.
Vale.
2001.
Adrián Blanco, tienes dos picks para joder el equipo que has empezado configurando con la Minyamal.
Claro.
Ahora ya todo a peor, lógicamente.
Vale.
Extremo izquierdo.
Año 2000.
Brasileño del Real Madrid.
Vinícius Junior.
Vale.
Y...
Año 1991.
Liverpool, Países Bajos, Virgil van Dijk.
Me cago en la madre que te tengo.
Muy buena.
Confiaban que me llegase para el final.
91 van Dijk, ¿verdad?
Sí.
Y no se puede repetir club, tampoco.
Claro.
Y me toca a mí.
A no, le toca a Álex.
A mí sí.
Vale, pues...
Esto es de papel y boli, ¿eh?
Sí, sí.
Aquí estamos.
Vale.
Uf, espera, tengo...
Espera, de momento.
Voy a por Nuno Mendes.
Nuno Mendes.
Año...
Iba a coger a Raph, pero es del mismo año que Mbappé.
¿Qué año es Nuno?
98.
2002, Nuno.
Es un insulto.
Lo de Nuno 2012.
Y marcando faltas.
2002 como Pedri, ¿no?
Sí.
Yo voy a ir...
Año 99.
Sí.
Italiano, Gigi Donnarumma.
Muy buena.
Top.
Vale.
Me tocan...
Dos picks seguidos.
Me he caído sin portero.
Me acabo de dar cuenta.
Vale, dos picks seguidos.
Me voy a quedar con el mejor delantero del momento.
Harry Kane.
1993.
Inglés Idel Bayer.
Kane y Halland.
¿Eh?
Rarete.
Uno a la ruptura y otro entre medias.
Entre medias.
Uno baja a recibir y el otro...
Confiad un poquito.
El otro recibe a bajar.
Uno tiende a subir y el otro sube a atender.
Confiad un poquito.
Dejad de dar la nota.
Y...
Vamos a ubicar a...
Esta lección es complicada.
A...
Reciente balón de oro.
Usman Dembele.
Año 1997.
Francia.
Dembele está jugando de nueve también.
Miguel.
A Kenia Halland.
Tienes razón.
Con ojos antiguos.
No, no.
¿Te haré razón?
¿Qué más queréis?
No te hagas trampas.
No, hombre.
Algo tendréis que hacer.
Contra los tramposos.
Ya está.
¿De qué año era Arraja Kimi?
Del 98.
Pues Arraja Kimi...
Pon el culo del antorcho.
Por favor, madurate un poquito.
Arraja Kimi.
1998.
Te toca.
Nahuel Miranda.
Este...
Eh...
Y ahora...
¡Fundido a negro!
Fundido a negro.
Pues que ya no me acuerdo de...
Y se fundió y a su barco le llamó.
Libertad.
Tengo muchas dudas con este pick.
¿Eh?
Ah...
Voy a gastar...
Bueno...
Estoy intentando hacer una cosa, pero...
Verás.
No va a salir.
Es que la gente...
No lo va a entender.
La gente lo va a entender.
Pero si a ti lo de ir contra la gente te gusta.
Otra vez.
No sé qué pasa con la cámara hoy.
Eh...
Bueno, cosas del directo.
Se malea un poquito a veces.
Eh...
Mirad.
Voy a plegarme a las masas.
¡Uf!
Cuidado.
Porque yo quería hacer...
Yo quería hacer una cosa un poquito más creativa.
Quería yo dibujar una metáfora.
No, no, no.
Yo quería conseguir un compatriota
de este chat.
Que voy a seleccionar.
Pero bueno.
2001, Francia.
Nacido en Bondi.
Uy, en Salibá.
Gran ciudad, Bondi.
Salibá, Mbappé y...
Randa. Había otro, ¿no?
Mati Stel, puede ser.
No, Mati Stel es de Sarcells.
Pero ha estado bien para taparlo de Randall.
O sea...
Estamos contigo.
No, pero he estado a punto de pillar a Dayot.
Y te has plegado, ¿eh?
Me he plegado.
Porque luego me dicen que no es el mejor once.
Y bueno, quiero...
Más que tener la razón, me gusta ganar.
Dale,
querido Dejano.
A mí no me toca, ¿no?
Yo voy después de Adri.
Te toca a ti, Dejano.
Vale.
Pues...
Sí, le toca a Dejano.
Yo antes, ¿eh?
Claro, le toca a Adri.
Que no, que no. Que he elegido yo.
Eligen a Uel y luego le toca a Álex.
Y luego dos veces a Adri.
Sí que sí. Vale.
Yo lo conté a todos.
Venga.
Le toca el pick número uno y ya está llorando Adrián Blanco.
Es increíble.
Yo voy a coger, señoras y señores,
procedente...
de...
Argentina.
A...
Julián Álvarez, Atlético de Madrid, 2000...
y Argentina, claro.
Vale.
Doble punta, ¿no?
Va a ser un...
Sí, Mbappé Julián.
¿Año has dicho?
2000. Adrián Blanco, ahora sí.
Parera.
Vale.
Voy a coger...
Mmm...
año 2001.
Vale.
Paris Saint-Germain,
ecuatoriano,
William Pacho.
¿Centrales?
Van Dyck, Pacho. Ya tengo centrales.
Y...
la siguiente...
Es que elegir dos es difícil, ¿eh?
Sí. Sí lo es.
Eh...
Tenemos ya. Tengo...
Venga, voy a utilizar un comodín.
Comodín, comodín.
Año...
1985.
Sí, venga.
Cuarenta añitos en la criatura.
Croacia.
Sí, señor.
Luca Modric.
Venga.
Año, has dicho...
Bueno, si es este...
va a ser difícil que...
porque es el mismo año de Cristiano, pero no sé si alguno va a coger a Cristiano.
Vale.
Álex de Llano, que tienes
a Nuno Méndez, a Moisés Caicedo,
a Mbappé y a Julián.
¿A quién eliges?
Pues... voy a empezar
con los centrales y mi primera elección
es Gabriel Magalláes,
del Arsenal.
1997 y brasileño.
Vale.
Gabriel, 1997.
Nahuel Miranda.
Tienes a Don Aruma, a Salibá,
a Vitinha y a Mosala.
Mosala.
1997,
Fútbol Club Barcelona, Frenkie de Jong.
Uh...
Buen centro del campo.
Sí. Sí, sí.
1997. Vale.
¿Y Álex ha elegido a quién?
A...
A Gabriel, 1997.
Uf, gastar Brasil con Gabriel,
cuidado, ¿eh?
Tranquilo, todo responde a un plan.
Sí, sí.
A mí me gusta el plan.
Una huertita.
Vale.
Vamos...
Es difícil, ¿eh?
Hay de todo aquí.
Vale.
Vamos a ir.
Chuchuchuchuchuchu.
Momentín.
Vale.
No tengo ninguno del 97,
¿verdad?
Que no voy a liar.
No.
Tienes a Raz del 98, PediRi2002,
Keen93 y Haaland2000.
Vale. No, no voy a hacer esa.
Lo cual es una doble punta muy extra.
Voy...
No te ha gustado, ¿eh?
Bueno, hay que generar opinión.
Voy...
Un momento, ¿eh?
Hostia, lo que voy a mamar es el lateral derecho.
Es que claro,
hay que pensar ya en clave
de lo que se viene,
que es muy chungo.
Cuidado.
Lo tiene.
Vale.
A ver de qué años este pago.
Uf, uf.
Joder.
Este ya lo tengo cogido.
Uy, uy, uy.
Ey, ey, ey.
Y pequeña.
Vale.
¿Año? ¿De qué año es este?
A este no lo tengo cogido.
Voy a ir con...
Ah, no, sí, tengo ya un jugador del...
Ay, ostia.
Ay.
Que bien.
El gado se...
Claro, es que mientras yo voy apuntando vuestras cosas,
yo tengo...
Yo no me da tiempo para pensar...
Yo también voy apuntando. Miguel, no eres especial.
Solo eres un pobre tramposo
que no sabe por dónde salir en esta.
Tramposo.
Vale.
Eh...
Voy a ubicar a...
Saca ya.
A Gildiz, año 2005.
Turquito,
banda izquierda.
Turquito.
Turquito, ¿no? Es turquito.
Y a...
Ostias.
Enzo Fernández, argentino, año 2001,
junto a Pedri.
Nahuel Miranda.
Eh...
Esto es complicadísimo, hermanos.
Sí, ahora ya es chungo, ¿eh?
Esto es jodidísimo.
Jodidísimo. La que me voy a tener que
tirar en portería.
Esto va a ser histórico.
Ay, no puedo.
Eh...
Necesito un segundo.
Necesito un pequeño segundo, ¿eh?
Yo, por suerte,
ya tengo el portero.
Es que el portero hay un portero muy claro,
pero bueno, ya tengo portero.
Claro, yo ya tengo uno...
Vamos, yo puedo elegir ya a Courtois,
y no podéis ninguno de vosotros.
Así que me lo guarda ahí.
Estrategia.
Muy listo.
Muy listo, dice el otro.
Eh...
Es que... O sea, voy teniendo
cosas claras, que no tenéis vosotros.
Pero claro.
Nada, yo me voy a tener que tirar
un triplazo histórico.
Se engraben.
Y me falta toda la línea de arriba,
la madre que me parió.
Bueno, en realidad me faltan dos extremos.
Que es complicadísimo.
Este juego es muy chungo.
Es muy complicado, sí.
A quién se le ocurriría...
A los clubes de por medio, tío.
A quién se le ocurriría este juego, eh, Nau?
Sí, sí.
Felicidades, Nau.
Gran trabajo.
Un saludo para la madre del topo.
Un segundo, perdón.
Sé que está quedando largo.
Lo sé, soy consciente.
Me duele a mí más que a vosotros.
No, no te duele a ti más que a nosotros.
Joder, tío.
No se me está ocurriendo.
Mira, voy a...
Voy a quitarme lo de medio.
No, es que necesito...
Tío, es que necesito los laterales.
Necesito los laterales.
Es que la media punta, vosotros tenéis ya todo
prácticamente apañado.
Necesito laterales.
¿Por qué no hay años?
Es que hay que jugar con los años
totalmente.
Ah, tío, pero es que...
Joder, perdón, eh.
La que me voy a tirar.
La que me voy a tirar para el centro.
Ah, tío, pero ¿por qué juegan todos en clubes buenos?
¡Tengo!
Encontrar un futbolista y que el puto año ya lo tenga.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Increíble.
Eh...
Tío, ¿cuántos clubes repetidos tengo?
Por favor.
Está colapsando.
Esto es imposible, eh.
No encuentro jugadores.
Eh...
A ver, necesito este año.
98...
Vamos.
España, 1998.
Marco Ucureya.
Vale.
Bien. Bien.
1998 has dicho, ¿vale?
De Llano.
Míralo, se le ve el pelo.
Dejadme.
Dejadme un momento.
Un segundito.
De nuevo, el equipo de Llano
es que no se le queda una buena idea.
No, no, la verdad es que
ya estamos viviendo...
Mola, mola.
Creo que ahora mismo está todo
muy guardado, depende ya la estrategia
que haya seguido cada uno
y lo que se ha ido guardando.
¿Sabes lo que pasa?
Yo he dicho, ah, vale, tengo a este,
pero lo puedo cambiar a este otro para darle
este hueco a este jugador
y ahora no me acuerdo cuál era
el que he dicho
esta edad me cuadra.
Espérate un momento, que era uno del 96.
Vale, un momentín.
Eh...
Creo que era...
Creo que era un portero del...
Espérate, un portero del 96.
Todos... ¿Vosotros ya tenéis portero, no?
No, yo no.
Pero Adri, ¿tú tienes el 96 ya pillado?
Eh...
No te lo voy a decir.
Joder. Muy bien, Rey.
Muy bien, Rey. Bueno, pues da igual,
me voy a asegurar este y a tomar por saco.
Mi central zurdo es Bastoni, 1999,
Inter y italiano.
Putisima madre caballito.
Pero si...
¿Has dicho Bastoni?
Bastoni, 1999, italiano,
Inter.
Vale.
Eh... Adrián Blanco,
dos jugadores.
Vale. Eh...
Año 1993,
Atlético de Madrid,
Esloveno,
Jano Black.
Vale.
Y... Eh...
Alado entre dos.
Venga, año 97,
Inter, Argentina,
para muchos el mejor delantero de la historia,
Lautaro Martínez.
Vale.
Vas a un 4-2-3-1, ¿no?
¿95, Lautaro?
¿97?
No sé, depende de si encuentro media punta o no.
4-4-2,
ofensivo como el mío también,
no estoy para enjuiciar.
Álex de Llano.
Bien. Eh...
Vale.
Eh...
Vamos, Álex, a la...
a la...
Tú lo haces fenomenal.
Fenomenal, como una palmera,
suave, suave, su su su suave.
Vale. Eh...
Voy a ir a por el...
No, me cago en...
Pues no has dicho nada todavía, espérate.
No, no, no.
No he dicho nada. Espérate, hombre, espérate.
Qué dolor.
¿Qué ha pasado?
Que había un jugador que me encajaba del carajo y nada.
Venga. Eh...
Banda izquierda,
desde Corea del Sur,
jugando actualmente la
Major League Soccer, Hugh Minson.
Miso de 192.
Oye, pero lo de banda izquierda...
Es left winger, eh.
Álex, Álex,
ha escogido a Hugh Minson.
O sea, quiero decir...
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Chavales, llevan ocho goles y nueve partidos de MLS.
Delirante, Álex De Llano.
La que os voy a hacer.
No, mierda.
Lo del año...
Lo del año es mortal.
Lo del año es muy doloroso.
Había encontrado a un extremo que era...
Lo peor, lo peor.
Había encontrado un lateral derecho de reciente cuño.
Pero...
Es el año 98, eh.
Sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, bueno, es que,
tío, es que va a ser histórico.
Es que va a ser histórico.
Tío,
¿qué pasa con el lateral derecho?
Yo tengo uno muy bueno.
Comparte, bro.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
Eh...
Joder, he bajado
hasta...
Esto es imposible, tío.
Esto es bastante complicado, sí.
Eh...
Lateral derecho...
Espérate, a ver.
Ahora que sea del año.
Lo del año, macho. Lo del año...
Lo peor.
Eh...
Este me encaja, pero ahora el otro.
Ay, perdón, solo se me da el pelo.
Eh...
No llevo ningún español, soy una antipatriota.
Joder. Vale.
Año...
Es que es un delito gastar este
comodín aquí, pero bueno.
Año 2002, lateral derecho
brasileño, Jan Couto.
Ostras.
Empiezan
los porros. Empiezan los triples.
Empiezan los porros.
Porque problemas
graves.
Vale. Eh...
Voy a empezar a solucionar un poquito
el tema que tengo montado
con el puesto central porque no tengo a ninguno.
Vale.
Ibrahima Conaté.
1999.
Vale.
Francés.
Eh...
Ostia, no.
Conatés, ¿de qué año?
1999.
¿No?
O lo he mirado mal. Igual lo he mirado mal.
No sé. No sé. No sé.
Me suena muy joven. Igual es otro año.
No, sí. 1999.
Bastante joven.
Eh...
Dadme un segundito, porque
tenía aquí apuntado
un nombre que me convencía.
Y que creo
si me encaja de dad
por lo...
Lo para que esté...
Es que me parece...
¿Qué es lo que dice Nahuel?
Coger a este...
Ahora...
Es que... Madre mía, yo estoy embarajando
una opción. Luego la contaré cuando
acabemos, pero...
Vale. Es que no puede ser.
Vale.
Un segundito.
Eh...
Que tengo una
duda, pero no sé si...
A ver.
Que me gustan los...
A ver, ¿de qué año es este?
A este no le puedo coger,
así que descartado.
Y a este tampoco le puedo coger, así que
descartado.
¿Se puede 4-3-3? Sí, sí.
Se puede.
Ojo, cómo en este.
Vale.
Un momentín, ¿eh?
Voy a hacer una...
Es que
la gente igual, al otro lado, no se
imagina lo complicado
que es...
cuadrar todo.
Que lo intenten y no nos lo digan.
No, pero luego sí, claro, con cinco horas
en casa... Claro.
Es muy fácil.
Eh...
Qué fácil es ver los ojos desde la barrera,
Miguel Quintana.
Vale.
Me acabo de palmar con este.
Vale, pues voy a tirar con este.
Fuá.
Vaya, honor Alberto Chogo.
Lo voy a hacer aquí, niño. Vale.
Hago una comprobación y si no
estoy...
Este año...
No lo tengo.
Bien.
Vale.
Eh...
Federico Di Marco, 1997.
La de al izquierdo.
Italiano.
Coja a Rogeri, hombre.
Estoy reservándome
el puesto de central para
Clement Lenglet.
Adri, por favor.
Vale, te toca, Nahuel Miranda.
Es muy difícil.
El portero...
El portero yo estoy flipando.
Hay uno muy claro que no habéis cogido ninguno.
Sí.
A mí el portero me va a llevar a cometer una locura.
No se odiega... Piensa bien, Alex.
No se odiega.
Yo sé a cuál os referís, pero no se odiegaís.
Que mame un poquito.
Dejadle que mame un poquito.
¿A quién le toca? A Nahuel.
Sí, pero...
Pero problemas, eh.
¿Tú crees?
No tengo nadie del Barça tampoco.
Pero Joan es que no puedo por Joan.
Santo Dios.
Es que los equipos...
Me parece lo de menos.
Aquí no repetir equipo...
El problema es el año.
Pero complica, eh.
Sí, sí.
Pero a mí lo que me parece mortal es el año.
El año me parece mortal.
Porque tengo dos buenas opciones para la banda derecha
y para el puesto central y no me cuadra por el año.
Ya, a mí el año es lo que más me ha jodido.
Sobre todo para la portería.
Ay, cabra bestia.
Es que esto es imposible, tío.
Es imposible.
Este perro poder nació un poco más tarde.
Un día, coño, un día.
¡Perro!
Es que esto es imposible.
Bueno, eh...
Me voy a gastarlo ya y así me dejo de historias.
Aunque creo que no podéis ficharlo ninguno.
¿Quién?
Pero...
2003, Jude Bellingham.
Vale.
Mediapunta.
Sí, mediapunta.
2003, vale.
Yo soy muy de Florian Beats, pero...
que es 2003 también.
Pero ya tengo Liverpool.
Yo también estaba viendo, sí, sí.
Sí, sí.
Alex De Jano.
Vale.
Lateral derecho.
1996.
Crystal Palace, Colombia.
Muy bueno, muy bueno.
Yo también lo tenía ahí como combo.
Yo lo he visto y he preferido lo de Goat.
Pues es que no vemos a Premier.
Pues entre el año...
No, a palo.
Entre el año de la Copa del Rey,
no, entre... A ver, a palo.
Entre el año y...
Y eso a mí me...
Yo prefería
a Daniel Muñoz y Colombia.
El hecho de que no te va a comer.
Pero que Goat es Brasil.
Sí.
Pero que tampoco hay tanto para elegir de Brasil, eh.
Sí, yo por eso he cogido a Gabriel.
Sí, no es fácil.
Los clubes están todos los puñetes...
Claro, eres un brasileño y pateas bien un balón
y de repente estás en un club top.
Es tremenda.
Vale.
Adrián Blanco, te quedan dos.
Sí, sí, sí.
Vale, sí, estaba haciendo comprobaciones.
Voy a cerrar lo del lateral derecho.
Año 99.
Chelsea, Inglaterra.
Chris James.
Vale.
Ehm...
Año 95.
Alemania.
Bayern, Joshua Kimmich.
Qué cabrón, vale, pues ya está.
Ese centro del campo,
o sea...
Centro del campo, Kimmich,
Modri, la mina a un lado y vices al otro.
Y que defiende tú,
que a mí me da la risa.
¿Puedes repetir, Adri?
Eh...
Chris James, año 99.
Y Kimmich, 95.
Yo iba a coger a Kimmich,
porque ahora entenderéis por qué iba a coger a Kimmich.
Te toca, Álex.
Explícanos por qué has cogido a Jim Inson, Álex.
Que no tenga sentido.
A ver, eh...
Todos tenéis portero?
No...
Sí.
Yo no.
Tú tienes un español, ¿no, Miguel?
Tú has cogido a Pedri.
Sí.
Pues entonces voy a coger a
Tijani Reinders,
del Manchester City.
No, y Paisas Bajos.
En el centro del campo.
¿Qué año es?
97.
Tienes a Gabriel.
¡Ostras, verdad!
¡Salta turno!
Eso no ha ido nunca así.
Año 2004,
Gambia.
Cojo a Jacubo Minte,
del Brighton. Extremo derecho.
¡Pero, mira!
Igual tú ves demasiada Premiere.
¿Qué año has dicho?
Jacubo Minte.
Sí, sí, pero ¿qué año has dicho?
2004.
Lo bueno es que ya ha cogido
Gambia, entonces el resto lo podemos coger nosotros.
Vale.
¡Ostras!
¡Ostras, chaval!
Gambia que no.
Gambia.
Vale.
Te toca
a U, ¿verdad?
A ver.
Es que todos tenéis
9, es que falta el central.
Falta el central, es que falta el extremo de izquierdo.
Falta el 9.
Esta es un soplicio.
Es muy chungo.
Mira, me da igual que me lo quitéis,
pero tengo bastante claro que mi nueva va a ser
Víctor Osimén, año 98.
¡Ah, no! ¡Mierda! ¡Tengo cucurrea!
¡Mierda!
Pero bueno.
Por favor, hablad bien.
Por favor, chicos.
Pero bueno.
Pero por favor.
Qué dolor de cabeza.
Vale, equipito, voy a hacer un video.
Vale, equipito, voy a hacer, niño.
Los que juegan al Fútbol Manager van a saber mi equipo.
Es que tengo un central, pero...
Pero bueno.
Chicos, decidme el portero. ¡Venga, hombre!
Que no.
Que putada del 98, ¿eh?
Son todos del 98.
Sí, sí.
Esto vi el otro día que había
un juego muy popular, bueno,
que lo compartían en Twitter, que decía gente
que lo hacía en los pubs en Inglaterra,
que es adivinar el jugador
que tiene 27 años.
Porque es una edad muy curiosa.
Los 27 años ya no eres ni promesa,
ni, ¿sabes? Ya eres un poco viejo,
¿ven ya, no? Increíble
los pubs, ¿eh? Inglés.
Tío, son todos del 98.
Esto qué es.
Marco Curella fastidiándote el juego, ¿eh?
Como diría Paco González, ¿no?
¡A mamar!
Qué asco de juego.
Eh...
Es que...
A ver, a ver.
Dame una alegría. Dame una alegría.
¡Mierda, no!
Joder. A ver, es que tengo
97, 98,
2000, 2001, 2002 y 2003.
Es que...
Y 99, claro. Es que del 97 al 90...
Al 2003
tengo todo pillado.
Eh...
Si el portero vaya a tener que pillar a...
A este volumen.
Pues mira, mi 9 va a ser Lewandowski,
del 88.
Esto ya.
Tiro la toalla ya, ¿eh?
Raro.
Pasó este juego ya.
Parece que está en una discoteca. Me voy con la del 88.
El suplente
de Ferran Torres
ha salido.
Vale, me tocan dos.
Ah, no, claro. No puedo Lewandowski.
Claro, tengo a Frenky de hayon.
¡Dios! ¡Dios!
¡Jajaja!
Coge a Yakuha, miente.
Jajaja.
Eh...
Santo cielo.
Es que todos los que
salen arriba en los valores de mercado...
Los valores de mercado son la mentira.
Ya, bueno, pues es que es la forma más
rápida de ir buscando.
Ya, ya.
Sí, sí, yo estoy también.
No, no, es que estamos todos...
Claro.
Navegando...
Por la infrarrete. Es que es imposible.
Es imposible.
¡Ah! ¡Ah!
A ver, ¿qué años tienes tú? 97.
Voy a tratar de tomar por culo. Es que, claro...
No encuentro jugadores.
Me encantaría darle más ritmo, pero no encuentro jugadores.
O sea, esto es un sin vivir.
2001, pillado también.
Eh... De verdad, tío.
De verdad. Meta a Nahuel Tenaglia ahí en la defensa.
Es que Nahuel Tenaglia está en la
horquilla. ¡Ya he pasado por Nahuel Tenaglia!
Jajaja.
Eh... Es imposible este juego, eh.
O sea, esto solo se le ocurriría a...
A ti.
A ti, psicópata.
A ti, psicópata. A mí no.
A ti.
Por si os estáis buscando, voy homo es del 2001, ¿vale?
Jajaja.
Eh...
Oye, que... Qué grande.
Estoy pasando páginas de centrales y todos...
O tengo ya el club o...
No, no. Es una locura. Es una locura.
El generado hay que hacerlo rápido porque si no, mueres.
Eh... Pues mira.
Antonio Raello.
Me voy a pegar un tiro con lo que voy a elegir.
Robin Koch, ¿vale? Año 96.
Claro, jugar al mejor equipo del mundo, realmente,
si te paras a pensarlo.
Pero, pero... Eh...
Acaba de pasar lo que acaba de pasar.
O sea...
Que no hay centrales, Miguel. No hay.
¿De qué año has dicho que es, Nahuel?
Del 96.
Ay, el 96 hay otro muy bueno.
Don Omar.
Mejor que Robin Koch. Hombre, claro.
A ver.
Eh...
Un suplicio esto, eh.
Creía que tenía a un central perfecto.
Ya habéis escogido todos centrales, ¿no?
Sí. Sí. Tenía a Slotterbeck.
Pero, gau, ya tengo a Konaté del año 99.
Que sí, que sí. Es imposible.
No le de más vueltas.
Bueno. Eh...
Voy a hacer con el delantero y con el extremo.
O sea...
Vale.
Eh... A ver, espérate un momento.
Yo tengo ya mis dos selecciones.
Yo tengo mi equipo de cerra, ¿eh?
Y estoy muy contento con ellas.
Espero que no me jodáis.
Una no os va a gustar, me os vais a reír,
vais a decir...
Lo de siempre, ¿no?
Lo de siempre... No, no sé qué...
Estamos hablando de solos contra todos.
Sí, sí. Incomprendido.
Incomprendido.
Eh... Mientras voy buscando
por darle un poquito de ritmo, voy a coger
a Tibo Courtois en portería, año 1992.
Vale.
Vale. Y...
Eh...
Es que...
Es un porro, tío.
A ver, Elec.
Busco un...
Los equipos son porros, la verdad.
Bueno, habla por ti, ¿eh?
Hombre, Adri. El mío es un equipazo.
A ver. De todo es un porro como el de todos.
Vas a flipar ahora cuando lo cierre.
Estoy viendo...
Vale, vale, vale.
Es del... Me cago en...
Estaba buscando en Beumo, en banda derecha.
Sí, en Beumo. Pero es que el año es lo que jode.
Es del 98, ¿no?
Del 99. Ah, 99, eso.
Es que tenía Bastoni. Pullisic, año 98.
A tomar por culo.
Oye, oye.
Vete a Son, vete al año de Son.
Que hay calidad.
Anthony Elanga, no puedo. Año 2002.
Sí, Anthony Elanga lo tenía yo también mirado.
Porque es sueco.
Claro, es que...
Eh...
El que más me ha dolido...
Ya no lo podéis coger.
¿Tenéis todas banda derecha?
Anthony me ha dolido muchísimo no cogerle.
Yo es que he preferido tener una buena línea de centrales.
Al final tengo a Mbappe y Julián arriba.
Jiminson, que todavía tiene mucho que dar.
Y a Cuba Mente, que es un...
Velocista, regateador.
Como dice Skycedo, cubriendo las espaldas.
Mi equipo es el que está...
Mi equipo es el que está mejor balanceado.
Ahora veréis el toque de magia que le voy a dar.
Vale. Eh...
Joder, escraño 2000 también.
No puedo meter a Kudus.
No, Kudus a mí también me ha jodido porque tenía Julián.
Un segundo.
Ah, mira.
Ah, no, que tengo a Gildi.
Tampoco puedo a Chico con Seizao.
Anda, vaya por Dios.
Madre mía, es que esto es un...
Voy, voy, voy.
Voy, voy.
Por darle ritmo, eh.
Sí, sí.
Cinco obras tenían los de casa.
Voy, voy, voy.
Un segundito.
No, no pasa nada, si te damos todos los segunditos que quieras.
Es que es muy difícil.
No, para el resto no.
Mira, crack.
Un segundo.
Necesito encontrarlos.
También podéis ayudar.
Sí, claro.
No, pero te quise.
Por colaborar, ¿sabes?
Sí, sí.
Venga.
Este año lo tengo.
2003.
Venga, va.
En como puesto de central, Antonio Silva, año 2003.
Bravo.
Como han ido cayendo vuestros equipos, eh.
Sí, claro.
Antonio Silva, ¿qué año?
2003.
Ven, Adri.
No, no.
Le toca a Anahuel.
Yo creo que a Anahuel la ha tocado hace nada, eh.
Claro.
Año 95.
Eh, a ver.
No.
Te falta un delantero y un bando de izquierda.
Sí, pues mira.
Año 95.
Inglés.
Ah, no.
Tengo a Jude Bellingham.
Pero tan difícil es no copiar la nacionalidad.
Es tan difícil callarse un momentito.
Año 93.
Eh...
Nápoles Romelu Lukaku.
93, has dicho.
Sí, sí.
¿Cómo?
Perdón.
No, no, no te mutees.
Me llama mi hermana.
Ya, ya.
Joder, mi hermana. Ah, Irene.
Vale.
De Llano.
Te falta un portero y un bandadero.
Y un centro campista.
Venga, voy con el portero.
¿Qué preferís antes?
Tengo los dos y los dos los podéis copiar.
¿Cuál que preferís?
Da uno.
¿Vosotros ya tenéis central todos?
O sea, portero, perdón.
Espérate, que se me ha desenfocado esto.
Vale.
Te...
Venga, voy a por el portero.
El mejor portero del mundial de clubes,
que estaría jugando en donde le diera la gana.
Ese era.
Y a Simbo Nú, 1991, Marruecos.
Vale.
Adrián Blanco,
te tocan dos.
Y acabo el equipo ya, creo.
¿Tenéis todo el portero? Sí.
Yo quería que veáis a Pierre Sainoil.
Ostras, no he caído.
No tengo ninguna alemana.
Tampoco...
Bueno, prefiero a Volumar.
El portero del Bayern.
No, ya, pero te quiero decir que tampoco...
Me he quedado con Kimic.
Venga, acabo el equipo ya.
Juega.
Estaba aquí y yo lo he llegado, pero es que se ha pegado un repaso histórico.
¿Qué dices, loco?
Lateral izquierdo.
Año 2002.
¿Qué?
No lo tengo.
Italiano del Arsenal, Calafiori.
Bueno, Calafiori,
repaso histórico.
Espérate.
¿Quién es el tuyo?
El mío, Nuno Méndez.
Ahí has estado poco fino, eh.
Qué joder, Adrián.
Espérate.
Y media punta,
año 94, Portugal, Manchester United,
Bruno Fernández.
Os he pegado un repaso con el equipo
histórico, chavales.
A ver, chicos, una cosa.
Si nos ponemos...
Luis James, Bandaek,
Pacho, Calafiori, Kimic, Modric,
la mintzama, Vinicius, Bruno
y Lautaro. Vete con mintz
a otro lado.
¿Qué años Luis James?
Si nos ponemos
finos,
Bruno Fernández,
desde que llegó a Morín, juega en el doble pivote,
no juega de media punta.
Entonces, claro,
a mí me parecería raro.
Que se permitiera
intercambiar alturas.
Es un juego muy fluido.
Y además hay que decir
que podría poner el 4-3-3.
O podría poner a Bernardo Silva.
O sea que tampoco
está tan mal.
Yo puedo cerrarlo ya.
Bueno,
pues mi apuesta por el talento joven,
por ser un equipo vertical,
por querer tener la pelota y sobre todo
porque
me cabe por año y por equipo,
es
año 2006
Lucas Berbal,
sueco del Tónam,
va a ser mi acompañante
Moises Caicedo y el que cierra
mi equipito, mi equipín
que no pretende ser...
Pero ¿qué equipo tiene? Madre mía.
Mi equipo no pretende.
Pergunzoso, ¿verdad?
Que la gente lo
valore, simplemente quiere dar
espectáculo a la cancha. Así que...
Os lo digo,
os lo recito, os lo
narro.
Yacín Bonu, Daniel Muñoz, Gabriel Magalláes,
Bastoni, Nuno Méndez,
Moises Caicedo, Lucas Berbal,
Jacob Amintegeun, Minson, Julián Álvarez,
Mbappé. Tú dime qué línea
flojea de este equipo.
Tengo mínimo
un top mundial por línea.
Es verdad que, puestos todos así,
no hay ninguno que flojea.
Claro. Flojean todos.
O sea, ha sonado raro
Jacob Amintegeun, pero claro, joder, Jacob Amintegeun
como extremo derecho de un
equipo que le puede doblar Daniel Muñoz,
que puede meterse hacia adentro, que puede
ponerle 100 a Mbappé o Julián.
Cuanto más lo explica,
peor suena. Es una cosa tremenda.
En cambio, tú poniendo a Robin
Koch, que ha quedado el equipo cojonudo.
¿Coch?
¿O nudo?
No, no, a ver,
ha ganado Adri, claramente
además, porque encima
mi extremo izquierdo para cerrar el equipo es
Andrés Schilderup, año 2004.
Cabrón, que
justo acaba de beber agua.
He desconectado los cascos,
los estoy dejando escuchar.
Joder, qué equipos. Hostia, hostia.
O sea,
el momento
en el que se va...
Que es decir, que mi equipo sea una mierda
no convierta al tuyo en bueno.
El momento en el que subamos
esto a Instagram, la gente
ve a Andrés Schilderup
de extremo izquierdo.
Bueno,
he estirado de llano por lo de que
equipo muy de fútbol manager.
Yo en banda derecha
para cerrar mi equipo,
Riyad Mahares,
1991,
Argelia. Bastante contento
la forma en la que ha acabado. Podría haber acabado
con el Schilderup diestro,
pero he acabado con Mahares.
Así que, bueno.
Bueno, esto es un porro histórico,
este juego es una
basura. Muy choco, muy choco.
Repasamos los equipos.
Adrián Blanco con Jano, Blarri, James,
Van Dyke, Pacho, Calafiori, Luca,
Morik, Kimic, Laminha, Malbruno, Fernández, Vinicius
y Lautaro. Creo que el
mejor. Alex de Llanó,
creo que el peor con Bonu,
Daniel Muñoz, Gabriel, Bastoni,
Nuno Méndez, Minte,
Moises Caicedo, Berwal,
Son, Mbappé y Julián Álvarez,
Nahuel Miranda.
Es que de llano no está para hablar.
¿Cómo va a ser el peor?
Si tengo a Mbappé y a Julián. Tengo al mejor lateral
izquierdo del mundo, al mejor lateral derecho
de América. Tengo a uno de
los mejores centrocampistas del planeta.
Como Moises Caicedo, una de las grandes
promesas del fútbol mundial. Como es Lucas
Berbal, Hugh Binson, que me va a dar
el último servicio como hizo en la Mili
con Corea del Sur y como está haciendo ahora con
el EFC. Yakuha Minte, que es un
talentazo. Nahuel,
Gigi Donnarumma, Giancotto,
Saliba, Kog,
Marco Curella, Vitinha,
Dejon, Moserajus, Bellingham,
Selderup, Romelu Lukaku.
O sea, Selderup, Romelu
Lukaku es mejor que Minte.
Es verdad que es el
de Nahuel y hay mucha competencia por ser el peor.
Yo creo que me quedo segundo, aunque sea solo porque
no hay participantes.
A Raph, Conaté, Antonio Silva,
Di Marco, Mares, Pedri,
Enzo, Fernando,
Gildiz, Haaland, Harry Kane.
Estoy más cerca de vuestros equipos
que del diadri. Lo reconozco.
Haaland, Harry Kane.
Haaland, Harry Kane, doble, nueve.
Mejor eso que tener a André
Selderup en banda izquierda.
Hasta aquí este draft.
Ha sido duro, ha sido difícil.
Espero que haya sido divertido.
Si alguien se anima a hacer su equipo
con los restos,
comentar.
Adelante.